the police's Focus was rightly on
ensuring this momentous occasion passed
safely and without major disruption that
was successful all the plots to disrupt
the coronation were foiled by a
combination of intelligence work and
proactive Vigilant policing on the
ground
I would like to thank and congratulate
the police for this success
at the same time extensive wait wait for
it at the same time extensive planning
ensured protests could take place this
was also successful
hundreds of protesters exercised their
right to peaceful protest including a
large group numbering in the hundreds in
and around Trafalgar Square
now where the police reasonably believed
they had grounds for arrest they acted
the latest information is that 64
arrests were made I won't comment on
individual cases or specific decisions
but the arrests included a person wanted
for sexual offenses people equipped to
commit criminal damage with large
quantities of paint and arrests on
suspicion of conspiracy to cause public
nuisance often backed by intelligence
the Mets update last night included
regret to use their word that six people
arrested couldn't join the hundreds
protesting in Trafalgar Square and
nearby the Met has confirmed those six
people have now had their bail canceled
with no further action Mr Speaker the
police are operationally independent and
for the Met it is primarily for the
mayor of London to hold them to account
but let's be clear
at the weekend officers had to make
difficult judgments in fast time in a
highly pressured situation against the
threatening intelligence picture I thank
the police for doing that for delivering
a successful coronation and for enabling
safe peaceful protests
a chuck